and first lady Jill Biden tested
positive for covid-19 over the weekend
the White House confirmed the test
result on Monday and says she is
experiencing only mild symptoms
officials say President Biden is testing
negative but doctors will continue to
monitor his condition the first lady
will remain at the couple's home in
Delaware for the time being and finally
in
a first lady
last night I can tell you that the first
lady is experiencing mild symptoms and
will remain in Delaware for the week
President Biden tested negative last
night for kova 19 and tested negative
again today he's not experiencing any
symptoms as far as the steps he is
taking since the president was with the
first lady yesterday he will be masking
while indoors and around people in
alignment with CDC guidance and he as as
has been the practice in the past the
president will remove his mask when
sufficiently distance from others
indoors and while outside as well the
CDC guidelines recommend a combination
of masking testing and monitoring for
symptoms the president is doing all of
that in close consultation with his
physician